das krasse war dann allerdings dass sie
geantwortet hat works das stärkste
mädchen der welt nahm es locker und
schaut mal mein t shirt
surmann day heute ist montag und das
heutige video sehen sie ich denke jeder
von euch hat mitbekommen und zwar habe
ich ja vor zwei tagen dieses video
hochgeladen
das schönste mädchen der welt naja ich
bin verliebt ja
habe in diesem video auf einen tag im
leben des schönsten mädchens der welt
reagiert das ist ein video von
wissenswerte und ich habe mich verliebt
ich meine das schönste mädchen der welt
das ist jetzt dies jetzt halt auch nicht
so hässlich allerdings würde ich sagen
schauen wir uns jetzt erstmal einige
kommentare an die unter diesem video von
mir gepostet wurden nächstes video ich
ziehe nach frankreich ich fühle mich
gerade so hässlich wie noch nie
schönheitschirurg was ist denn ihre
ungefähre vorlage ich top london
ich ernähre mich ungesund bin aber
trotzdem dünn ich ernähre mich
überwiegend gesund macht jeden tag sport
und sehe aus wie eine kartoffel wissen
querte sieht hat mit sieben ihren ersten
job als schauspielerin bekommen ich mit
7 as st lukas titel das schönste mädchen
der welt auf dem trail ein kind das
definitiv unter 18 ist ich bin ja
champagner
champaign provence normandie europa geht
ja so habe ich dann habe ich dann
französisch gesprochen in dem video
da darf ich auch viele bosse bekommen
also danke auf jeden fall dafür ich
hatte sieben jahre französisch auf dem
gymnasium von daher arima klose
literatur labor alemannia dann die wir
an das bedeutet in etwa das ihren daumen
hoch da lassen sollte main kanal
abonnieren auf die glocke klicken weil
dann verpasst sich auf jeden fall habe
ich in meinem video wo ich halt auf den
typischen tag von thilo blondeau
reagiert habe auch gesagt könnte man
alle auf den kauf von ihr gehen und sie
fragen ob sie vielleicht irgendwie mit
mir ein eis essen gehen will wenn das
mit
zwar halten
das
nicht ernst gemeint von wegen hey
schreibt ihr und fragt sie ob sie mit
mir ein eis essen gehen will allerdings
habe ich halt nachdem ein video online
war das in meiner instagram story
geteilt und habe dort auch das hier
reingepackt ein bild von ihr aus ihrer
wohnung mit dem schriftzug sie wohnt in
paris und danach auch dieses video hier
noch frankreich
das war ebenfalls ironie daraufhin habe
ich dann allerdings war meine die ems
gecheckt und habe dann beispielsweise so
etwas gesehen wenn sie das wild sieht
kommt sie direkt nach deutschland und er
das foto an gehandelt wo ich meinen
nackten hintern präsentiert habe diese
dm habe ich zum beispiel auch bekommen
werden wir ist meister lukas 11
wie bereits in meinem video vorgestern
oder vor drei tagen ja gesagt
schönheit liegt im auge wyss und dann
ging es mittlerweile echte sonne stalker
richtungen und zwar wurde mir dann
beispielsweise auch sowas geschickt das
ist eine story highlight von der tür wo
sie in münchen war also in deutschland
und eine andere person hat mir dann auch
geschrieben fragt man die waren hier
auch mal in köln könnte mal im hotel
nachfragen ob du da die adresse da
irgendwie nie welches hotel auf jeden
fall habe ich mir dann halt gedacht hey
das sind einfach ein paar die ms und bin
dann halt mal auf instagram in meine wer
was kommentiert oder mich erwähnt oder
was bei mir leid dieser diesem tag da
bin ich rein gegangen da kann das hier
und zwar hat von logi mich in einem
kommentar erwähnte youtube london und
brot problem dem man den laser nun kommt
nur sympathie potro wird laws affäre emi
die andere front von sondhi m simon
jäger job ja wie danté französisch die
einst als mir das jemand übersetzen kann
er hat unten in den kommentaren würde
mich auf jeden fall mal interessieren
allerdings habe ich dann auch mal unter
ihrem letzten hochgeladen und instagram
ausgeguckt das war nicht vor fünf tagen
irgendwie so eine kooperation mit sonder
parfüm mark und da hat ja der kommentar
wurde darüber geschrieben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
europa service kommentar am eis und
youtube alle warner lugano monnet adrian
auch bitte dann in die ich hab das ganze
dann sogar noch ein bisschen weiter
gesponnen und dieses foto hier
hochgeladen
ja das bin ich früher vor vor acht
jahren am eiffelturm gewesen allerdings
ging es dann wirklich erst so richtig
los als wenn dieses hochgeladene
instagram foto von mir aus paris von
frühjahr so der auslöser gewesen wäre
dass der stein jetzt nicht nur auf der
spitze ist sondern jetzt und dann mit
voller kraft wollte wieder runter ich
echte nobelpreis verliehen für meine
vergleiche meine markierten beiträge
sind auf jeden fall explodiert auf
instagram nachdem ich dieses alte fotos
aus paris hochgeladen habe zudem habe
ich halt auch noch eine story gepackt
das nicht das definitiv nicht wegen
fehler gemacht hat und auch den standort
dieses foto hat beispielsweise lawine
photoshop und zwar in das einfach ich im
als kind mit ihr als kind das ist vor
allem richtig gut geworden auch luca hat
dieses foto hier gemacht hat auch helfer
4300 likes da bin ich irgendwo rein
gefolgschaft wo sie da irgendwie am
strand war oder so und der ort ist da wo
die liebe nie endet alles klar du hast
es auf jeden fall überhaupt nicht
übertrieben das bild hier fand ich auch
stark das habe ich ja vor ein paar tagen
hochgeladen von früher aus paris vom
triumphbogen einem davoser einige
photoshop dann wird sie hier auch
dreimal rein geführte schockiere das
bild hier auf jeden fall auch stark da
steht sie vor dem auto oder hier wo wir
auf der damentoilette beide 111 ii im
spiegel gemacht haben also das war auch
wahnsinn was allerdings auch wahnsinn
war war dass dann viele leute auch
dachten jo wird photoshop die einfach
mal wie sie sich küssen hier
beispielsweise oder hier haben sie das
auch gemacht oder hier so ein bisschen
schlechter und auch hier so im
disneyland aber kommt ihr klar die hat
einen freund und bei diesem bild hier
wollen wir gar nichts zusammen
photoshop sondern da wurde einfach
geschrieben das schönste mädchen der
welt und luca ja ich sehe dagegen
wirklich außerdem mülltonne
wenn man das mit fußballspielern
vergleichen würde wer ist so
star-stürmer bei real madrid und ich
wäre
bank wärmer bei lüdenscheid nord in der
jugend dritte kreisklasse meine
vergleiche sind wieder bombe allerdings
sind wurden auf jeden fall noch viele
viele weitere bilder bevor der schoppe
und ich habe jetzt gar nicht alle mit
reingenommen und das war immer noch
nicht an die spitze denn rewe hat auch
mein video gesehen und hat twitter
geschrieben auf instagram hello my
friend laser luca ist in love with you
alles klar
alles klar die denkt wahrscheinlich
überhaupt nicht dass ich bescheuert
werden das krasse war dann allerdings
dass sie geantwortet hat works das
stärkste mädchen der welt sie hat
geantwortet hahahaha und reger daraufhin
wieder geschriebenen story to be you are
here is really into you get what i can
tell at least a ha also mal ganz kurz
auf deutsch übersetzt gewährt
geschrieben hallo mein kumpel laser luca
ist völlig verkeilt sie hat geschrieben
haina dreh wie geschrieben sorry dass
ich dich hier gerade ab aber er steht
wirklich voll auf dich also das ist
zumindest das was ich darüber sagen kann
katri wie geschrieben sie hat daraufhin
wiederum mir antwortet hh des cube no
worries also sie meint quasi das ist ja
süß
einzig mit dass jetzt mich oder die
nachricht von revidiert 3 wieder noch
geschrieben jeder hieß auf keine gute
sache und herbert enough of the century
and stay wie sehr das ganze gesehen und
die nachrichten gelegt und
ich weiß nicht ob es das besser macht
oder die ganze situation nur noch
verschlimmert auf jeden fall habe ich
den screenshot von riestedt verlauf den
er mir geschenkt hat dann auch meine ins
remstal gepackt und meine reaktion
darauf hat gefilmt irgendwie bin ich
froh dass ihr so aktiv sein und mir bei
sowas dann helfen wollte aber bitte
macht das handy video auf die welt auch
schon überlegt diese tür oder wie sie
heißt einfach zu blockieren damit die
nicht sich dann denkt brauchen wir
später den namen von diesen typen gehe
ich mal auf seinem profil und dann zieht
die das war halt wirklich eine taktik
die ich verfolgen wollte und zwar wurde
mir wirklich so unangenehm ihr müsst
euch vorstellen dass ein 19 jähriges
mädchen aus frankreich die hat einen
freund und dann kommt irgendwann die
youtuber andrea geht auf der tag und die
komplette community von mir von luca
also ihr die luke ruth rasten einfach so
komplett aus und photoshop 1000 bilder
ich würde mir auch denken bei denen
selber mehrere schrauben nicht ganz
locker ich habe sie allerdings dann
nicht blockiert sondern ihr eine
nachricht geschrieben
gestern nacht und zwar hey days ago
erregte video showing typical danger
live community crazy in photoshop
pictures of a cease trade order to let
you know der deswos in my attention ende
der rutsche autogas wird your friend
sorry für den kombinierten expected luca
und darwin hat sie mir das hier
geschrieben
gar nix habe ich mir dann gedacht so
quasi heute nicht am handy story
gepostet
sie ist jetzt auch nicht irgendwie bei
einem shooting oder so neese sie ist
einfach zu dem bett wird nichts zu tun
[Musik]
es ist schlimm
schrei baby aber
ich war schon öfter oft in so tiefen
löcher ich brauche kurzen moment
wisst ihr was der unterschied ist
zwischen mir und dem hier der flasche
richtig es gibt keine
lange rede kurzer sinn meine lieben
freunde ich möchte das video jetzt auch
mal ein bisschen zum ende bringen
ich bin auf jeden fall gerade nochmal
vielen instagram account gegangen und
habe halt einfach nur das sie gesehen in
ihren markierten bildern von den letzten
neun sind mehr als die hälfte
irgendwelche photoshop bilder von mir
und ihr und mir wird das langsamste der
der unangenehm und ich finde es geht ein
bisschen zu weit was einige von euch da
veranstalten ich fand alles lustig es
ist auch überhaupt nicht schlimm ich
wollte ich glaube auch dass keiner
irgendwie ansatzweise etwas böses im
sinn hatte irgendwie sie zu nerven mich
zu nerven keine ahnung was war eine
lustige aktion aber brief an der stelle
möchte ich wieder das alexa band meine
lieben freunde ich hoffe euch hat dieser
kleine recap der ganzen situation
nochmal gefallen ist jetzt auch ein
bisschen ausgeartet soll ich mal meine
reaction hat er jetzt nach zwei tagen
hat das ganze jetzt irgendwie annähernd
700.000 aufrufe also erst ein bisschen
wellen geschlagen mit der tür
allerdings werde euch das video hier
gefallen hat dann das gerne einen daumen
hoch unter die medien da wie bereits
gesagt übersetzen wir gern das
französische unten in den kommentaren
ich werde an irgendeinen kommentar davon
allerdings befinden wir uns jetzt auch
im auto bei einer lieben freundin findet
hier um ein smiley eingeblendet wenn ihr
darauf klickt könnte ihm einen kanal
kostenlos abonnieren
und wenn ich schon mal da würde ich mich
sehr freuen wenn ihr unter dem video auf
die glocke klickt allerdings kann auch
ein neues video auf einem zweig analog
zu online gegangen und verendet dieses
video so weit sein das wort alter sagt
also klickt das ich fahre jetzt nach
frankreich